welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
we're going to be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
2020s first big horror movie The Grudge
throughout this video we'll be going
over the main plot elements of the film
including its overall storyline and
ending there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to see
the film yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now
chances are though that you haven't seen
the film and you just wanted spoiler we
all get that 166 thousand subscribers so
yeah I'm not judging you for click in
this video anyway thanks for checking
this out Happy New Year now let's get
into our breakdown of the grudge
your husband told me about your
condition and I'm here to see if I can
help
this is Madison who you are right okay
so the events of the grudge actually
play out in a non chronological order
and the timeline jumps about from year
to year throughout the film in order to
tell the entire story this is something
that's always been a big aesthetic of
the franchise but to keep everything
streamlined I'm gonna be putting the
events in the order that they happen
just so you don't get confused up top
though in order to understand the film
you have to understand what the grudge
itself actually is at its most basic
level the grudge is a curse that is
formed when someone dies in a state of
either extreme rage or sorrow after
passing away their spirit becomes
attached to a location most commonly a
home if someone is to enter the property
and unwittingly encounter the spirit
they will be followed by it and once
they die the curse is then reborn it's
pretty much right like a forwarding
chain letter that spreads almost from
person to person and location to
location in affecting all who come
across it now what it basically means is
that the horror is inescapable and no
matter where you go no matter what you
do the spirit will eventually come for
you whilst this is a terrifying idea it
also makes for a quite predictable
storyline as we do know that eventually
the characters will also come to their
fate with no chance of escape the grudge
is basically a virus that contaminates
people and spreads from person to person
this is a very straightforward ghost
story but as mentioned earlier where the
creative team tried to vary the film a
bit is through their use of the timeline
that the events happen in and by
reordering everything and they're able
to tell a more interesting story the
movie itself opens in Japan 2004 we join
a live-in nurse named Fiona Lana's and
follow her and her family the Landis who
become big players in the storyline
after witnessing some disturbing things
in the Tokyo household she encounters
ghosts and these curse her bit of trivia
this is the cursed location from the
original 2004 film starring Sarah
Michelle Gellar and this is the starting
point of the curse the detectives in
this film referenced the detectives from
the original movie and the
correspondence between the offices are
the same desperate to escape Fionna
flees to America
wittingly taking their malevolent
spirits with her later in the film we
learned that Fiona murdered both her
husband and daughter and then commit
suicide cursing her home in the timeline
this is where we joined the Spencer's
two real estate agents named Peter and
Nina that are expecting their first
child
unfortunately they discovered that their
unborn baby has the red genetic disorder
Ald this is a real-life disease that
ravages young children and though
initially they may seem healthy
eventually the child will begin to
regress pick up solitary behavioral
traits and then suffer from blindness
deafness seizures loss of muscle control
and dementia this either leads to death
or disability and it's a really horrible
disease that puts the two in an almost
impossible situation they don't know
whether to abort or keep their child but
eventually they settle on raising it and
appreciating the time that they have
left the film is very much about making
the most of the time that you have and
throughout the movie there are several
characters that deal with loss death and
living on borrowed time however they all
strive to do their best and turn lemons
into lemonade though yeah it's a bit
difficult when a killer ghost is trying
to murder you and your whole family
anyway a police investigation takes
place not long after and detective
Wilson and detective Goodman are called
to discover exactly what happened
Goodman refuses to enter the house after
he gets a funny feeling but Wilson does
and this is when he's infected by the
grudge
Wilson sees an apparition of Fiona and
slowly he's haunted by spirits until
he's driven to suicide unlike the others
though this attempt fails and Wilson
survives shooting himself which leaves
him massively disfigured he's put into a
psychiatric Asylum
where he lives in constant fear that a
ghost will come for him during this time
the Spencer's have listed the Landis
house and Peter comes face to face with
the ghost of Melinda the Landers
daughter unfortunately this doesn't
really have a happy ending and a cursed
Pierre ends up murdering his wife and
unborn child before dying himself now
one of my biggest problems with a grudge
outside of the over-the-top jump scares
is that it's very very bleak I know it's
a horror movie but this film feels like
it's purposely just ruining people's
lives but me personally that's not
really something that I find that
entertain
and I would rather watch complexities
and character arcs than the mall being
doomed to die which is what happens here
it's a sort of film version of the ald
disease and whether intentional or not
they do line up quite a lot now whether
you find it entertaining watching
someone just decay until they die is
probably going to set the level for how
much you enjoy this movie but in my
opinion the bleakness makes it hard to
really become invested in this lack of
hope is exemplified in the Matheson's
who we join in 2005 they move into the
land is home and become infected with
The Grudge the Matheson's are made up of
William and faith and the latter suffers
from dementia faith begins to witness
the spirit of Melinda around her home
and though she is initially joyful and
playful with the ghost things quickly
change when it becomes more menacing
William left with little options calls
for a suicide consultant named Lorna who
monitors faith and stays with the family
witnessing firsthand exactly what's
going on she talks to William about this
who says he finds comfort in the ghosts
because it means as an afterlife but as
we know this series isn't about happy
endings
so faith murders him the next day and
slices of her own fingers yay
Lorna discovers this and tries to escape
but she's attacked in the car by a
spirit and dies at the roadside the
police later discovered this and this is
where we join who I consider the main
character in the timeline that is
detective Muldoon a widow who moved town
with her son Burke after a husband sadly
died from cancer
well doon is a policeman that pretty
much unearths the ins and outs of the
case and it's through her that we begin
to piece together exactly what's gone on
she's partnered up with detective
Goodman and they discover Lorna's car
and corpse in the woods
Goodman divulges about the curse on the
house and how death seems to follow
whoever enters it however against her
better judgment
Muldoon goes there and discovers faith
faith has taken to hospital and commits
suicide there and Muldoon continues her
investigation but she begins to be
haunted by the Landers this leads her to
visit Wilson in the asylum who tells her
that she's been cursed and that she will
slowly spiral into insanity much in the
same way that he did he tries to gouge
his eyes out and yet that's how I felt
watching this film I'm just kidding guys
it was it was great Muldoon discovers
the curses origins and how Fiona brought
it over
Japan and she's attacked by the Landers
once more in a last-ditch attempt to rid
herself of the spirits she travels back
to the house that the curse is seemingly
coming from and burns it to the ground
we'll get into how the ending differs
for international audiences and just a
bear but Muldoon seemingly defeats the
spirits and they burn to the ground with
the house well doon returns to her home
and embraces her son before he goes to
school however in the background we can
see another version of him the real one
leaving the house the child at Muldoon
is hugging is in fact Mel in there and
this shows that the curse is continued
and now found a new home we don't see if
it kills Muldoon or not but we can guess
that it will eventually catch up to her
once more the cycle will likely start
again with the house being investigated
estate agents listing it and the disease
will continue to spread from person to
person now where this ending differs
internationally is that this final scene
is never actually shown it's only
implied detective Muldoon still burns
down the house but instead of being
attacked by the ghosts at the end she
merely pulls up to the house and is it
and the credits begin to roll maybe
maybe that's the happy ending I was
looking for but it does kind of negate a
sequel and emphasize that the curse is
over whereas the main ending states that
it still exists so it's basically a pick
your poison here but going off the rules
of the curse I believe that it still
exists and has infected Muldoon as for
the film itself I really had a lot of
hopes for this especially with Sam
Raimi's name attached to it
but it fails in several ways making for
a very uninteresting and predictable
movie the grudges of franchise I feel is
kind of run its course now and the movie
cements that for me with it being a
waste of time rather than a compelling
journey if you bored and just want a fun
90 minutes then hey maybe this is the
one to check out this week for you but
for everyone else I just advise that you
steer clear I feel like I've been cursed
cursed every time I go the cinema is
just crap The Grudge sadly gets a 3 out
of 10 now obviously an allure to you
your thoughts on it and if you enjoyed
it this film is getting slammed by the
critics so I'd love to hear what you
enjoyed from it or if you didn't like it
like me yeah just let me know if you
like this video then please give
thumbs up and make sure you check our
full breakdown of this week's other big
release Dracula which is gonna be linked
at the end we go over everything that
you need to know about the show and its
ending so it's definitely worth checking
out if you have any questions if you
want to come check to me after the video
that makes you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which you'll be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of the
last year and all you have to do to be
and when the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on The
Grudge in the comment section below but
when is going to be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and a set will be
shipped out from the end whoever gets
the prize so best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe huge thank you for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace